[Music]
the award-winning chef and owner of the
bakery milk bar is now also a children's
author christina tosi is out with a book
called every cake has a story it aims to
inspire kids and stretch their
imagination meg oliver bought her son
cormic and his friends rishi maddie and
morgan to milk bar in new york city to
chat with tozie about the book and also
to create the cake of their dreams
how about this you could make a cake
using the cinnamon roll as the cake
christina tozi still thinks of herself
as a creative kid i have a dream to make
a pancake
into a layer cake that i want to call
the pancake cake
strike a pose she loves to play and
inspire young bakers to dream of the
yummiest toppings what are you guys
gonna dream on strawberry i can see the
wheels turning maybe the chocolate like
the caramel that's my girl she's the
force behind a baking empire from our
famous milk bar stores in new york city
and beyond all over to countless baking
shows fake squad 60 seconds and the
author of several delicious cookbooks
but just recently the 39 year old cake
and cookie queen revealed her greatest
creation a baby girl tozie's first child
that's probably my proudest title to
date yeah the proud mom to
eight-month-old frankie is also the
author of a children's book called every
cake has a story it's about a little
girl named sammy who lives in a town
that's stuck in a rut but comes alive
through the creativity in baking sammy
is like this little girl she lives in
samesville everything is black and white
everyone eats the same meal every day
wears the same clothes everything is
kind of just the same
and she yearns for more that is very
much the way that i felt when i was her
age i yearned for like more
possibility and more individuality and
space for creativity does samesville
symbolize part of your childhood
i think so a little bit i grew up in the
suburbs i loved going to the grocery
store that was like my thursday night
chore with my mom up and down the aisles
the cereal aisle are you kidding me the
baking aisle the different like
frostings and sprinkles and crumbs and
crunches like i thought of all the
different things that i could go home
and sort of like mash up and a little
bit of like a mad scientist way what was
your favorite part of the book when the
color showed up when the color showed up
why it was weird written in black and
white it was much more alive much more
alive much like everything was much more
creative everyone
would you ever want to live and sing
still
no
what's the message you want kids to take
away from this book
the message i want kids to take away
from every cake has a story is that
life is to be lived on your terms
yeah
that you are the first and only you and
that is the most powerful thing that you
can ever have in this world you have it
now it's just a matter of doing
something
positive and productive with it in the
world that is the secret to life
how's this yeah
there we go
a secret she wants to spread far and
wide
for cbs mornings i'm meg oliver in new
york